- [Judge] Joseph, please.
And who is this?
- Oh, who is this right here?
This is my 12 year old daughter
who I raised all by myself
without the help of anybody
else in the entire world.
She is my inspiration.
- Joseph, it doesn't matter.
There's nothing you can do or say
that's going to make us
change our minds today.
- That right there, that right there.
That's her daughter.
She blind.
(thumping sound)
Come on.
(judges gasps)
So I raise 'em both by myself
without nobody else's help.
- Come get your ticket to Vegas.
♪ Oh I want you, but I don't need you ♪
- [Person In Red Shirt] And two.
(scatting)
♪ There goes the girl who owns my heart ♪
♪ I knew she was the one
right from the start ♪
♪ Our love is here to stay ♪
♪ Each and every day ♪
♪ We know that we will never part ♪
(scatting)
- Wow.
Great work everybody.
Troy, I love that little
Motown outro thing.
Super soulful.
- Cool, thanks, Lyle.
Yeah, just came to me so I went with it.
- Wow, it's crazy.
- [Mark] Hey, is this where
the acapella group meets?
- Oh, hey Mark.
- Hey Lyle, what's going on buddy?
- Mark, get over here.
Guys, this is my buddy Mark.
He just transferred from Minnesota.
I thought he could sit
in on a few practices.
I don't know, maybe join the group.
- Yeah, maybe.
(intense music)
(laughing)
- All right guys, let's do
"Always Been My Girl" again
from the top.
- "Always Been My Girl"
Okay, I know that
- And Mark,
show us your stuff.
- You got it, man.
(chuckles)
- All right, guys, ready?
One, two.
(fingers snapping)
(scatting)
♪ There goes the girl who owns my heart ♪
♪ I knew she was the one
right from the start ♪
♪ Our love is here to stay ♪
♪ Each and every day ♪
♪ We know that we will never part ♪
(scatting)
(oohing)
(laughing and clapping)
- [Lyle] You gotta be kidding me.
Mark, that was out of this world.
- Gosh, okay well hey, it just came to me
so I just went with it.
(intense music)
- Great, well keep going with it.
Guys, have a safe weekend, all right.
See you on Monday.
- Nice to meet you guys man.
- Yeah.
- That was awesome.
- Isn't he the best?
- Cool, guys, great practice.
- [Lyle] Troy, good effort.
- All Right.
(clapping)
(laughing)
Yeah, check you later, guys.
See you later alligators.
(dramatic music)
- The (beep) do you
think you doing (beep)?
- I'm doing my thing
(beep), (beep) you doing?
- See this is my seven white boys (beep).
(scoffs)
You need to back the (beep) up.
- (beep) that (beep).
I'm 'bouts to get mine.
- Do you have any idea how long it took
for me to infiltrate this group (beep)?
25 minutes.
You think I'm going roll over
for some falsetto ass mother (beep)?
(pushing)
- Well, you know what (beep)?
White boys is goin' do
what white boys is goin' do.
And if they wanna run
with a high ass singing falsetto (beep).
Then that's on them.
- Oh, that's on them then?
- Oh, that's on them.
- Okay, so it's like that.
- Oh, it's stole like that.
- Well watch your back (beep).
- Okay.
- Watch your back (beep).
Cause you (beep) with my (beep).
I (beep) with yo (beep), (beep).
(laughter)
- [Narrator] And improvise.
- Oh, it's so cold out,
it's gonna be dark soon.
- Oh my God, yeah, we should build a fire.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, oh, I can't, no, oh, fire, fire.
- Freeze.
(claps)
Oh no, it's a black cat.
- Hey man, why the cat gotta be black?
(people laughing)
- Freeze.
(dramatic music)
(door closing)
Man, I guess I gotta put my dick away.
(laughing)
(dramatic music)
- I'm so glad we could bring this project
to this neighborhood.
- Oh, it's so rich in history.
- I grew up in a neighborhood like this.
- Oh yeah, I grew up in a
neighborhood exactly like this.
- All right, welcome to Mama Sugar Banks.
Y'all ready to order?
- Yeah, can I have a chicken fried steak
with gravy and a cola?
- Okay.
- I wanna have the baked beef short ribs
with collard greens and throw
down some of that cornbread.
- All right, baby.
(clears throat)
- You know what, hold up a second.
I'm also gonna have some
of them collard greens
and cornbread as well
but hook a brother up with
some of them hot links.
- [Server] All right.
- All right.
(laughs)
- You know what?
Why am I trying to front?
Scratch all that.
Give me some okra and
some fried red snapper
and girl, you know I want some chitlins.
- [Server] All right, now.
- Y'all got ham hocks?
- [Server] Of course.
- Well, that's what I want.
I wanna plate of ham hocks.
Deep fried, blackened and served
on a bed of mustard greens.
- Pig feet.
I want some pig feet and four pounds
of grits and oh, and you know what else?
Gimme a little Dixie cup
full of lard, all right.
(slamming sound)
- I just remember what I want.
A bowl of mosquitoes.
None of them tiny ones either.
Gimme them big mother (beep)
you find down at the swamp.
- Sister, could you
please hook a brother up
with a rusty bucket full of fish heads
wrapped in razor wire.
- Donkey teeth.
- Donkey teeth?
- Straight out a donkey's mouth.
You know what?
(beep) it, any animal tooth will do.
I want you to stick it
in some honey glaze fry
with fat back and serve it
in an old tin coffee can.
- Forget everything I said
up to this point right now.
Bring me some dandelion greens,
a cow hip and a dog face.
Wrapped that whole mess
in an old Ebony magazine.
And serve it to me in a shoebox.
- Okay, I wanna platter
of stork ankles, an old
cellar door, opossum spine
and a human foot.
- You want a human foot?
- Mhm.
- I got just one question for y'all.
You want gravy on that cellar door?
- Oh, definitely.
- Oh yeah, yeah you
got to put gravy on it.
- Yeah, what's a cellar
door without gravy?
- That's not food.
(laughing)
(intense music)
(gentle music)
Hmm, that's really.
(gags)
(scatting)
(clapping)
- [Narrator] And now, ladies and gentlemen
the man you've been waiting
for, Mr. Michael Winslow.
(crowd cheers)
- Go get em, Winslow.
Bring the noise, bring the noise.
Another sold out night for
the Kings of Mouth Noise.
I tell you though, we
wouldn't have this audience
without Winslow.
Lucky for you, huh?
(mouth noises)
Those police academy fans.
(clapping)
Look at all the T-shirts.
(mouth noise)
Six sequels, can you believe it?
Every sound effect this guy makes
is like a little tiny Mona
Lisa popping out of his mouth.
Have you ever heard him do
the walking through leaves in the fall?
(dramatic music)
(crowd cheering)
(door opening)
(door closing)
(breathing)
(spitting noise)
(wiping noise)
(thudding noise)
(swallowing noise)
(water sound)
(mouth noise)
(squeaking sound)
(buzzing noise)
(whipping sound)
(yelling)
(mouth noises)
(whooshing sound)
(swish sound)
(mouth noises)
(whooshing sounds)
(swooshing sound)
(mouth noises)
(clanking sound)
(swooshing sound)
(clicking sound)
(wobble sound)
(spitting sound)
(mouth noises)
(sheathing sound)
(swooshing sound)
(mouth noises)
(swooshing sounds)
(swooshing sound)
(clicking sound)
(gunshot sound)
(buzzing sound)
(heavy breathing)
(heart beat noise)
(beeping sound)
(mouth noises)
(beeping noise)
(flat line noise)
(siren noise)
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We met B-Boy
Joseph in Atlanta, GA.
- Hi Joseph.
- Sup?
(chuckles)
- Start the music.
(upbeat music)
- Has he started yet?
- Yeah, I'm pretty sure this is it.
(upbeat music)
- Thank you.
- Yeah, thank you.
- Yeah
- I ain't done yet though.
- Thank you, Joseph, it's
definitely a no for me.
- It's a no, I'm sorry.
- No.
- All right.
Thank you Joseph.
- Thank you.
- Cause you know, I ain't
got no formal training
or nothing like that.
I learned on the streets.
- That was very apparent as it turns out.
Joseph, thank you for coming.
- You know that my mama's on drugs
and my daddy in jail.
- It's not really relevant.
- Born in a coffee can under a bridge.
- That's terrible, Joseph.
That's awful.
But it's not going to.
- My sister shot my brother
while my cousin beat my uncle.
- Okay, now it's a lot.
- It's a little bit much.
Joseph, thank you very much, but.
- I put myself to school
by renting my body out
as a heroin suitcase.
- Alright.
- Wow.
- I see what's going on.
Joseph, please,
we do have other dancers here today
who are waiting their turn very politely.
No, Joseph let her come on stage.
- Oh, oh, jeez that's.
- Let her come.
No, Joseph.
- If I win this competition,
I could put a roof
over my house cause I got a
house that ain't got no roof.
For real though.
- Joseph.
- Just one little thing though.
- Don't do it Joseph.
- It was a loud bridge.
- Don't finish that sentence.
- I got hearing damage in this ear.
- Joseph.
- And also in this ear.
- The bridge had have trucks go over it.
- Joseph.
- Because the bridge.
- Keep it.
- 15 ton.
- Hold it.
Put it in your mouth and get off my stage.
- Rated six.
- Jo.
- That's a big truck.
- Seph, okay, Joseph, please.
And who is this?
- Oh, who is this right here?
This is my 12 year old daughter
who I raised all by myself
without the help of anybody
else in the entire world.
She is my inspiration.
- Joseph, it doesn't matter.
There's nothing you can do
or say that's going to make
us change our minds today.
- That right there, that right there.
That's her daughter.
(thumping sound)
She blind.
Come on.
(gasps)
So I raise 'em both by myself
without nobody else's help.
- Come get your ticket to Vegas.
(upbeat music)
(cheering and applauding)
- [Judge] Oh my God, yes, good job.
- Tremendous
- Did y'all see that?
- Can you believe it?
I'm getting goosies over here.
(laughing)
I'm getting goosies, I am.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh I want you, but I don't need you ♪